à faire respecter la loi plus
rapidement?
Voici l'avinenenenenenenenenen.
- La crise se poursuit à Ottawa.
Et les résidents se posent
Que fait la police d'Ottawa?
Le ministre de la Sécurité
publique du Canada se pose
maintenant la même question.
Bill Blair s'explique mal
l'inaction de la police
d'Ottawa.
manifestants sont bienenracinéss
possibilités d'intervention,
MARC PARENT, ancien directeurSel
- Ça a pris des proportions
définitivement complexifierlele.
- Les policiers d'Ottawa disent
de la crise, mais manquent
efefefeffectifs pour l'exécuter.
L'ancien chef de police d'Ottawa
changement d'approche s'impose.
CHARLES BOU,U,U,U, ancien chef
Service de police d'Ottawa
- Leur stratégie ne semblempmpmf
sur la réduction du nombre
de manifestants.
- Devant l'impasse,
considère le recours à la Loi
sumemememesures d'urgence.
Une loi temporaire, qui peut
être adoptée en snananananananaà
Ottawa de gouverner par décret,
et donc d'agir plus vite.
PATRICK TAILLON, prof. titulaire
- C'est certainement un outilqut
produire un effet d'ultimatum.
- En Ontario, le premier
ministre Ford a déjà déclaré
Mais cette mesure exceptionnelle
n'a pas dissuadé le noyau dur
de manifestants, signe que
nécessairement juridique.
- Ça prend , , , , , mais ça,
on n'en manque pas. Après, ça
prend une volonté politique ctc.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du Canada
- On doit être prêt pour toute
- Justin Trudeau a déjà affirmé
que toutes les options étaient
sur la table pour mettre fin....
Le premier minisoqoqoqoqoqoqué
un groupe d'intervention
ce week-end, mai
exprimé à nouveau sur la crise
qui secoue le
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,